-Our first guest tonight
is a talented actor
and Grammy Award-winning
hip-hop legend.
He stars in "Law & Order:
Special Victims Unit,"
now in its 24th season.
You can see new episodes
Thursday nights here on NBC
and streaming
the next day on Peacock.
Let's take a look.
-And by the way,
I got something for you.
-Hmm?
A bullet?
-Same caliber as the one
you got shot with.
You have to own your trauma,
or your trauma will own you.
-Please welcome back to the show
our good friend Ice-T,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How are you?
-What's up, Seth?
-Thank you for spending
your Halloween with us.
-Well, this is not
Halloween night.
I'm definitely
gonna go party later.
-Okay, good.
Yeah, that's --
For people watching, this is
before the mayhem starts.
-Oh, yeah, this comes on later
than -- when people get home.
-Yeah.
So they'll see you.
Hopefully they all --
when they're watching this,
they should know
that you're still out.
-Absolutely.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Last year,
you and your wife, Coco,
were Harley Quinn and the Joker.
Very well done.
Do you guys have plans?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. Coco's gonna be
this vampire.
You know, whatever she is,
she's gonna be sexy.
-Yeah.
-So a sexy whatever, you know?
-Right, right, sexy vampire.
-And then I try
to match that up,
so I'ma put on a cape
and some teeth and a wig.
-Okay. Seems like
you put less thought into it?
Is that...?
-Yes.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Does -- is this a situation
where you follow her lead?
Do you ever
come up with it together,
or do you just let her decide?
-I let her decide.
She usually pulls out about four
or five different outfits.
And then now we have Chanel.
-Yeah.
-So it's a bunch of costumes
going around the house
during the week.
And then when she picks
her final one, then I say,
"Okay, I can jump on it."
-Chanel is 6.
What does
she want to be this year?
-She went to school today.
She was a princess, of course.
-Yeah.
-Something --
they had to do something
to deal with the Renaissance.
-Okay.
-So they had a theme.
And then, tonight,
she's gonna be a vampire
with the rest of us.
-All right,
so family of vampires.
There you go.
That's nice.
Do people recognize you when
you're dressed as a vampire?
Do they go, "Oh, my God.
That's Ice-T, the vampire"?
[ Laughter ]
-They definitely recognize Coco.
-Yeah, that's true.
-They put it together.
Even when we're out, like,
you know, like, if we're out,
if we're at the airport,
somebody, they'll see her,
and they look,
and then they see me,
they go,
"Oh, I should've known."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
When you have the two together,
then it's definite.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Can you tell now --
You've been working on this
television show for twenty --
I guess, 23 years?
Is that --
'Cause you came in season 2.
-Came in last episode
of the first season.
-Okay, gotcha.
Technically you're in all 24.
-Yeah, I'm claiming all 24.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, we'll give you
the full 24.
But can you tell now
when people come up to you,
do they -- whether they're gonna
be someone who knows you
from "SVU"
or someone who knows you
from your hip-hop career,
music career?
-Nah, I can't
tell my fans right now.
-Yeah.
-It's impossible,
because hip-hop's 50 years old.
-Yeah.
-Hip-hop has gray hair,
so a hip-hop fan
could be 70 years old.
You could talk to somebody
with a cane, and they're like,
"I used to breakdance."
[ Laughter ]
You know what I'm saying?
So hip-hop is embedded
in our culture,
so I don't know if I got
a metal fan I'm talking to.
I don't know
if it's from a film.
I don't know. But, you know,
I don't really care.
If you don't like something I do
but you like something else,
you still like a part of me.
-Yeah.
-So I'm cool with it.
I really don't care.
A fan is a fan, you know?
-I think one of the things
about "SVU" --
Absolutely, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Absolutely.
One of the enduring qualities
about all
the "Law & Order" franchises,
you know,
they rerun all the time.
People enjoy them.
They weirdly --
Even though -- yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
That's very comforting to you,
right?
-When I first got on the show,
I was doing movies and stuff,
and I didn't understand
residuals.
And so the first year,
I did the show, and I'm like,
"I don't know how long
I'll do this show.
I don't know how long."
And then I looked --
My accountant showed me
this number after a year,
and I'm like,
"What's that number?"
And she said,
"That's residuals."
Now, you don't make residuals
from movies
unless you're, like,
Brad Pitt or somebody.
-Sure.
-You only make --
You get like a dollar
for a movie.
So I saw the number,
and I went from,
"I don't know how long
I'll be on this show,"
to, "I will be on this show
till they throw my black ass..."
[ Laughter ]
"...out in the street."
[ Cheers and applause ]
'Cause we're on Peacock,
we're on TNT,
we're on now -- right now.
-Yeah.
Are you upset right now
that somebody's watching this
when they could be
watching you on "SVU"?
'Cause you will not be getting
the same residuals from this.
[ Laughter ]
-You know that "blum blum"?
-Yeah.
-We call that
Dick Wolf's cash register.
[ Laughter ]
"Blum blum."
-Now, do you ever watch
an old episode of "SVU"?
-Not really.
I usually watch the show
when it first comes on.
-Mm-hmm.
-With everybody else.
What people don't understand is,
we shoot the show
out of sequence.
I'm not in every scene.
So when they watch it
on television,
we're watching it for
the first time, too, you know?
So I'm sitting there like,
"Wow! Yo."
Sometimes I don't
really remember who did it.
I'm like...
[ Laughter ]
Yo, you know?
Also, we shoot it
out of sequence.
So we might shoot
the court trial before we even
figure out who the -- you know,
so it's real jumbled.
But I can watch it once,
you know.
Some people walk up to me,
they go, "Yo, I've watched
every episode two times."
I'm like, we might need
to investigate you.
[ Laughter ]
It's kind of a dark show.
-Do you feel like people --
like, older people use this show
as a gateway to maybe introduce
their kids to the fact
that you had this hip-hop career
that a whole generation
might not be aware of?
-Well, thank God for YouTube.
And the thing of it is,
all of us that were involved
with hip-hop,
all the people in the audience,
30, 40, 50, 60,
they believe
that they're cooler
than their kids.
See, that's the one thing
hip-hop did.
It made you feel like
your kids are never
gonna be as cool as you.
So your kid comes in, "Oh,
I like Lil this or Lil that,"
and you're like,
"Hell no, Run-DMC!
Watch this. This is what
rap looks like," you know?
And you don't know nothing
about NWA.
So we -- our generation
pushes our generation
on the kids 'cause
we are cooler than them.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
The fascinating thing, though --
[ Applause ]
-Got to get your Adidas on,
kids.
You got to understand.
This is what it is.
-Isn't it funny that when I --
I feel like when my parents
introduced music to us,
they never had to be like,
"Oh, no, no, no, not this song!"
because that's --
with my kids, like, for example
you mentioned NWA,
and, like, you know, that's --
Again, that's what I grew up,
when I was driving
to high school and driving home.
And then I'll say to my kids,
"Oh, you gotta hear this one,"
and then I'm like,
"What am I doing?"
-It's okay.
-It's okay?
We got to push it through?
-'Cause we're cooler.
-Okay, great.
[ Laughter ]
I got it from the source.
-It's okay.
-This is your third book,
correct?
-It's my third book.
-So this is "Split Decision."
You wrote this with Spike.
Tell us who Spike is.
-Spike was my crimey.
Before I got involved in music,
I was in the streets.
I was breaking the law.
I was doing a lot of things
that were gonna end me up
in the penitentiary.
And there was a point in my life
where I decided,
you know, "I'm done.
I'm done.
I'm gonna
try to make this music.
I'ma do something."
Spike was trying
to be a rapper with me.
He went and did one more robbery
and ended up catching
a 36-to-life prison term.
So when he got out of prison --
he did 26 straight --
and when he came home, he said,
"I want to write a book."
I want to write
a cautionary tale
that tells people
that everything --
Everybody in this room,
you're one decision away
from basically
destroying your life,
whether you're getting
in the car with somebody drunk
or you just --
we make so many decisions,
and just all it takes
is one bad one.
And this book right here
shows you my trajectory,
which I became Ice-T,
getting to sit on your show,
and what he went through,
and it's a cautionary tale.
I think everybody
should read it.
They're gonna find something
in it that's good for them.
-Well, I really like the fact
that despite
those different paths,
it's very nice that you guys
came together to do this.
-Yes.
-And it's always nice
to have you here,
sitting on the couch with us.
Thank you so much.
-Absolutely.
-You guys, that's Ice-T.
"Law & Order:
Special Victims Unit"
airs Thursday nights here on NBC
and streams
the next day on Peacock.
We'll be right back
with John Irving.